this is how I look like whenever I see
yet another framework comparison article
pop up on medium right people tend to
ask questions like uh which framework is
better like just stop asking that right
uh because it's not that simple to say
framework a is better than framework B
but if you want to pick up a framework
properly the hard way then you have to
understand some of these internal
trade-offs the the Frameworks I'm making
right you have to be aware of
which direction this framework is
heading towards whether it aligns with
what you are prioritizing in the thing
you're trying to build scope how much a
framework is trying to do for you
a rendering mechanism
how a framework allows you to express
your UI structure and how it renders
stuff
and then there's the state mechanism uh
mutable versus the mutable dirty
checking versus dependency tracking
reactivity versus
simulated reactivity